عراق جديد في البرلمان الجورجي بسبب روسيا
هذه المره اشعل استئناف الرحلات الجويه
بين البلدين جدالا سرعان ما تحول الى عراك
بين المؤيدين والمعارضين للقرار
ابرز الاشتباكات بالايدي داخل البرلمان
وقعت في مرسى الماضي حيث تحولت قاعه
البرلمان لساحه معركه بين مؤيدين ومعارضين
لمشروع قانون حول حريه الصحافه الذي
اعتبرته المعارضه قانونا روسيا في ديسمبر
عام 2013 نشب عراك بين اعضاء في البرلمان
بسبب الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في اوكرانيا وخطط
دعم المعارضه فيها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات